is choice particularly strong issue  within the Hispanic community and if so  why it sure is especially in our  low-income neighborhoods just making  them aware of options that are available  to them is important because quality of  education that that's available to them  in those particular neighborhoods is not  significant is in getting school choice  more accepted on a broad basis well I  think in Florida where we're  headquartered is a perfect example where  we have been able to garner some strong  bipartisan support that choice is  something that makes sense it's not  something that's out of the box anymore  both Republicans Democrats the Hispanic  Caucus the African American caucus both  believe in this buy into this concept so  we're as early as five six years ago  there's only a handful of legislators  that that bought into this concept so  the more and more we grow this into  other states that the better off we'll  be